you know you talk about using that laser
tag system and when we started using
simunition
that paintball was just totally
different I mean imagine that
that paper Target doesn't shoot back it
doesn't move that's the main concerns of
the enemy they're gonna shoot back and
they're gonna move
yeah a paper Target doesn't shoot back
and doesn't move so
that training is even the live fire
training you have to do it and you need
to do it to a point where it's second
nature
live fire against targets
but the real stressors should come when
you start doing force on Force training
yeah
yeah that that's a just
the person or the enemy whatever
shooting back just that not moving thing
like what if there was stationary
targets that actually shot back just
that alone huge deal yeah on the flip
side just them moving around versus not
more huge deal totally and then now you
go now you're missing in live fire
training uh and there's obviously my
little Theory I don't sit in the
scenario but those two put together yeah
right isn't that kind of night in there
it's a whole different training scenario
and we adjusted our tactics when we
figured that out because our our tactics
had evolved from Vietnam
they had evolved to a point where they
weren't realistic anymore because we
spent all these we spent 20 years
shooting at paper targets that weren't
moving and so we developed tactics to do
it very quickly but it was against
inanimate objects the minute we started
getting
paintball and simunition into the game
you start realizing oh that's not going
to work we can't all stand in a big
group like this we need to take this
into consideration we need to take that
into consideration at all so things we
got a lot better we started doing Force
unfortunately it's the same thing to be
said for jiu jitsu and UFC right when
you just when I used to walk up to you
and throw like a whatever punch and you
would fall down like I threw a simulated
punch and you simulated falling down and
I simulated broke your you know your
heart with a with a two-finger punch or
whatever you know what I mean it's
called the dimmer yeah with the Dimock
then it's like it seemed to work good
that was pretty awesome yep but then the
minute I got into a fight with some
drunk wrestler I got caught a beat down
I'm like this doesn't work and what Jiu
Jitsu is Jiu Jitsu is like oh you're
training to
you training as hard as you can to put
the person in a submission hold that
then they don't die because they tap
well it's the same thing I shoot you
with paintball in the neck or the thighs
which is where I'm aiming because the
Art's the worst
so when I shoot you there you don't die
but you learn the lesson
so how different is it you ever played a
regular paintball yes just regular okay
so simulation that's the people that you
guys have what's the difference is there
any difference discrimination
simulation you shoot from your real
weapon yeah and it and it goes bang it
goes It goes bang not loud you know it's
not it's just a little it's a little
tiny bang uh you have to change your
magazine it's not like we you have 400
paintballs in a freaking Hopper on top
of your gun you're just gonna lay it
waste right you have to change magazine
they kind of simulation does Jam a
little bit uh which is a bummer what's
the um what would you call it the
propellant or whatever like how does it
it's an explosion yeah oh it's like a
little explosion and so and it comes out
I would I don't know if it comes out
like faster it seems to I think it's a
little bit faster I think it hits a
little bit harder then it's a smaller
projectile so it hurts a little bit more
oh okay but but it is it has paint in it
and you get you know you get a little
paint on you
and it's very effective it's uh the
thing the reason that we also use the
laser tag system is because the
paintball and the simunition is only
good for you know
30 40 yards
so it's good in the house it's good in
the hallway it's good in a CQC
environment but out in the field is no
good it doesn't work good you can use a
little bit like even in a mount
environment
you need to use regular paintball guns
eventually so that you can get some
distance you can put down cover fire
like across the street
but even that's not very that's not very
accurate
um but then but then the lasers they're
good at like three four five hundred
yards well maybe 300 yards but but
that's that's legit like you can get
some legit training
and do the laser and this is just my
predicting or estimating kind of
imagining so the one you're with the
lasers don't you lose an element of
stress a little bit because there's
nothing actually coming and hitting you
yep and what what was funny was so we
use those in the desert and if you got
shot you're gonna get put down and if
you got put down someone's gonna have to
carry you out if you're getting carried
out you're gonna get dropped you're
gonna get like it sucked for everyone
and so when it would actually
when you would watch guys going through
like a urban scenario getting shot with
paintball they would just charge through
it like they didn't care like the
instructors if they're gonna put you
down they put you down but when you on
the laser tag system it had a near-miss
little you had a speaker on your
shoulder so when you get shot at it
would go you know
make a little noise and you knew that
you were getting shot at oh that's cool
and when you would watch guys as those
near misses started coming they would
dive for cover
like they were getting shot at for real
I'm not kidding they were dive like they
were getting shot up for Widow because
they if they got shot
everything was gonna go to they
were gonna get bogged down other people
were getting shot they were gonna have
to get carried out which is a total gut
check and and it would happen a lot yeah
but you'd see those guys it was very
effective training yeah but sometimes
you know when you're just doing a laser
tag with no punishment whatsoever yeah
you can definitely get a little bit
cocky with paintball you don't really
get too cocky because it hurts and you
don't want to get you know you'll you'll
move from cover to cover yeah because
you don't want to get lit up yeah yeah
it's funny there's all those little
details that you don't really think
about that play such a big role in the
whole scenario oh yeah the guys diving
for cover and we're using the laser
system was that's when you knew like oh
this is really effective yeah
so and then you could also put down
suppressive fire because if you were you
know over in a building I could just
shoot at the building and as soon as you
started maneuvering out so you could
shoot back you'd like get near misses
and you'd hide oh yeah so that means I
could you know I could put down cover
fire while my buddy moved yeah and it
was totally effective
kind of makes a big difference I didn't
really think about it where especially
if you have that Association like oh if
I could put down this major consequence
sucks because without the speak because
I'm not thinking speaker does all that
which obviously is more advanced than I
thought so the if you're just like oh
you only get the indicator that you got
shot right which is kind of like the
regular laser tag yeah that I played
when I was young you don't they don't
know near misses nothing like that so
you think oh yeah copper firing won't
work that good because yeah part what
basically the whole concept of cover
fire is you being scared of those
bullets even though they don't hit you
but then yeah if you got that speaker
buzzing in here
oh but then but laser doesn't like hit
the building doesn't because hitting the
building is like kind of a big thing
right that will get your head down yeah
so cover fire in a way potentially
is way more effective in real fire for
all because it's everything yes and that
was one thing that was even with even
with the laser tag you'd still see guys
do like stuff where you're like hey
would you have really done that because
you got shot 19 times or whatever you
know and so it was a little hard to
simulate the fear of death yeah but I'll
tell you what getting getting buddy
carried or having to Buddy carry someone
out for six kilometers in the desert oh
not on night vision it sucked and guys
hated it and so they would do everything
they could to stay alive and accomplish
the mission yeah that feels like a solid
little like proxy yeah you know for uh
it was a solid little foxy
I mean obviously you can't shoot the
guys and kill them right but man it's
you don't want to hump someone out in
the desert it's freaking terrible uh
especially someone like you yeah and in
and sometimes guys would you know uh a
task unit would have
12 down man
it would just be awful like if they did
if they didn't if the leadership wasn't
making good decisions and they weren't
covered in moving if things weren't you
know simple and clear and they didn't
prioritize you'd get 12 13 14. and
sometimes you know we'd kill so many of
them and be like all right you guys are
done just walk back you you failed oh
yeah and that's when you're getting
reloaded and now you got a whole nother
stress right because they don't want to
get they don't want to fail of course
yeah so it'd be a bummer but it was
really good it was it was great to be
able to be a part of that training yeah
that that's that's cool how it evolved
into like that that close to realistic
yeah those paintballs like especially if
the simulation hurt more than like
paintball kind of hurts like it's
finishing hurts too yeah but I'd say
it's probably about the same yeah
probably about the same bro I got
whacked like a couple times like in the
side yeah and I wasn't wearing like
padding or nothing just the face one
yeah and yeah and leaves like a straight
up wound like on your thing like a
wealth or whatever
yeah that's that's something it's not
nothing I'll tell you that
[Applause]
thoroughness
realism in German training methods is
one aspect of their General demand for
thoroughness German officers in
particular and enlisted men as well are
taught to regard themselves as men
engaged in a highly skilled and highly
honorable profession and to take pride
in acquiring the details of military
techniques to encourage this point of
view soldiers are put as little
as possible on fatigue work and
non-military labors which are performed
by civilians
and the last thing we'll talk about from
this document is Marksmanship during
German training has tended to put
emphasis on volume of fire rather than
accuracy an observer believes that their
ability to concentrate fire at vital
point is superior to our own but that
their standards of Marksmanship are
inferior however a German article in
late 1941 makes the point that volume of
mechanical fire will not replace
accurate individual shooting and that
Sharpshooters can perform invaluable
tactical missions
so they
they did concentrate on volume of fire
and they concentrate on Marksmanship the
basic skills of shooting
and there you have it and and as you can
see
um
many of those principles
are the same principles that are taught
in the US Military and really the same
principles that are taught by any sort
of leadership
education
right and and that's why it's very
strange to read this document and
recognize that these principles are
being utilized by
the most evil or at least one of the top
evil Empires to have ever existed and
yet they're talking about taking care of
their people and and making sure
everyone understands the why
and you can see as I mentioned earlier
that that while these principles were
implemented down the chain of command
clearly at the top
these principles didn't exist at all a
tyrannical leader of Hitler massive ego
driven by his own insecurities driven by
paranoia lack of trust like all these
things that these book this book talks
about
the Hitler to them
and
that's why you end up in This Disaster
and this horrific
the the horrific atrocities that that
the Nazis created and the horrific
atrocities of the war
which which you know what you you know
you were talking about earlier I kind of
made fun of you about like oh the world
didn't exist before I was here right
it's it's kind of inconceivable
in some ways to understand the broad
absolute horror of World War II
and the Holocaust and the the deaths
the the woundings the loss of life the
destroyed
communities
it's it's it's kind of hard
to really truly understand that those
things occurred
at all it can be very difficult to
understand that
they seem inconceivable I guess
if you truly look at him it's easing it
seems inconceivable if you think about
the millions of people you know millions
of people
millions of people dying
it's hard to it's hard to understand a
million dollars it's hard to understand
you know a million a million people
going to uh uh you know at a big giant
Arena there's only a hundred thousand
people there
picture that times 10.
and then that's there you have a million
and each one of those people is an
individual with a family and dreams and
a life and and and thoughts
and when you start talking about the
scale of death and destruction in World
War II it's just
it's hard to conceive what that really
means but
it did happen
and
we
have to study history
and have to study our enemies and what
their thought processes were to make
sure that history does not repeat itself
with that we appreciate you all listen
to the podcast
if you want to support the podcast and
support yourself at the same time
might as well support some good causes
out there right let's support some good
it's true let's make the world a better
place let's start with ourselves yes
make yourself better yeah
physically better
mentally better
spiritually better
let's do all those things yep
take care of yourself on every front
that's what we need to do and then you
can take care of other people then you
can help other people so if you want to
help yourself from a fuel
and I'm not talking about gasoline for
your car or maybe diesel for your truck
talking about for you you need fuel yeah
similar concept similar concept you want
to get good fuel you kind of want to get
the best fuel yes sir you might want to
get for yourself some Jocko fuel
it's true yeah it's very true uh you
know as I keep reminding you off air
that I am on the path kind of strict oh
yeah yeah like kind of legitimately
strict
ever since um
covid
I put on some pounds some good some bad
and uh you know varying levels of
success in going back to you know to
where I was before that also I just got
back from the motherland away yeah and
you know how that can go sometimes but
then the last point is I'm on the path
so routine back in full swing 100 right
covet was like three years ago yeah yeah
it was uh you know like I said coffee
let's make a recommended don't go off
the path for three years everybody I
would say this so I was it two years
coming up on three years maybe two years
two years right and a half I don't know
something like that but I was like I'm
off the path because of covered well you
know two and a half years ago well Jiu
Jitsu stops for a long time
the routine Jiu Jitsu okay we got little
pockets here and there you get it this
is true but the routine stops you know I
still can work out at the house or
whatever but cardio goes way down
sometimes like Off the Grid let's face
it so I'm just lifting some woman please
yourself on full report
maybe someone else out there can relate
to the realities of situations like this
nonetheless boom yeah sure it got back
on the path but I never really got back
to where it was and after a while you
know we just got tired of that one you
know so we just went more strict that's
what I'm saying but there are certain
elements in there that have always been
on the path
especially with a few with the joker
fuel part of it part of the point as
well so well thank God you had Jocko
fuel because apparently you need you
were just you were just wand around
never mind off the path you're off the
reservation I know and the way I'm
putting is more like I just freaking
just let myself go I didn't let myself
go but I put on like a good
10 15 pounds which isn't yeah I know
it's not like night and day kind of a
scenario but
and that's probably why I didn't get
back right away because it wasn't like
that big of a thing but it was still a
nagging thing I feel like Chuck you see
I'm saying you're drinking milk I'm
drinking milk yes and actually I just
got on this um protocol which I always
knew about but you know sometimes it
takes a little bit for to implement
where if you if with your diet if you
just control for like the protein
getting enough protein whatever your
workout program kind of requires or
whatever
and then you fill in the rest of the
macros accordingly depends on where you
want to go what your goal is or whatever
that's like a really good way
to stay on it you see I'm saying like if
because if you don't control for protein
and you don't get enough protein you
don't build your muscle the way you want
to do it you risk over train you do all
this stuff whatever nonetheless it's a
better it's a good way to do it yeah so
you've got to get that protein yeah 100
how much are you getting uh hot one gram
per no like 6.6 0.6 grams per yeah
right that's like the you need to up it
man yeah you up those numbers from what
I understand I mean I wonder you're
losing weight you're starving to death
over there bro you're losing muscle mass
no but it depends on where what you read
and where you read it um that it's going
to go anywhere from like 0.5 all the way
up to like one oh is this per pound per
or per pound or per kilogram no per
pound
for real yeah okay it depends so um I
don't know hey look that's that's your
journey to look into that kind of stuff
and figure out what's right for you bro
okay so let's say I weigh 220. and I'm
taking you want me to freaking eat 220
grams of protein in a day that that's
what you're saying I don't know that's
10 mokes I love milk I like milk a lot
but bro I could you know 10 10. yeah
even if you break it up three milk
shakes per meal
I don't know I don't know okay we don't
recommend that I'm not saying yes I'm
not saying no I'm saying
currently I'm not at 10 no I'm at one
sometimes two I actually built mine are
doubles yes on mine yeah I only have
doubles okay yeah there you go boom
nonetheless
we're on the program 100 Jack
um also good news with the energy drinks
if you didn't know or anything yeah
real good news all the old good news is
still there healthy for you energy drink
no sugar sugar is more evil than you
think by the way yeah 100 I think it's
evil so you're not catching me on that
one I know as evil as I if you were to
you know how like I'm sure there's some
point in your life where you like looked
into sugar a little bit deeper than
maybe you do daily and then realize oh
shoot this is kind of there's some
issues with sugar sugar is real like
yeah evil you could start looking back
into it and probably find some more
stuff yep that's how so you're saying it
is even more evil than even I thought
and I thought it was pretty damn evil
that is my contention yes and
good news like I said old good news but
good news no sugar in this one so it's
all healthy stuff
so boom that's still the case but the
additional good news we got a
reformulated tastes in there for all of
them oh yeah all of them all the all the
discipline go tastes good as a hell now
like it will we're gonna win on taste
yeah we're gonna win on taste tastes
better than the other
let's what do we call them energy drinks
energy tastes better than the other ones
straight up better yeah try that still
no sugar yeah still no still no
chemicals in there just good for you and
now it tastes good too
it's true the other flavors you might
have had one or two flavors that you
liked but the other ones you kind of now
you'll like them all yeah you'll and
you'll love one or two of them that's
the difference that's what we just did
yeah and there was a few before that you
hated you won't even hate any of them
yeah
now you're gonna you're gonna like them
all you're gonna love two or three of
them
and you're gonna be good to go you're
gonna find your little thing yeah man
it's true it's all true chocola.com yep
uh don't forget don't forget a lot of
people we don't we haven't actually
talked about it whatever the joint stuff
that's a big deal because you can be on
any program but yeah if your joints your
knees start giving out shoulders all
this kind of stuff right you're kind of
off the program a little bit so
voluntarily off the program so yeah keep
that in mind you want overall health
you want to be able to keep going yeah
endurance endure durable be durable that
helps big time
um yeah some vitamins in there vitamin D
cold or immunity by just checking
chocolates.com go to Wawa get some
drinks we gotta we gotta ready to drink
common Mulk coming have you seen that
have you tasted it yet no it's hella
good yeah perfect perfect yeah it's so
good do they add like um you know how
for example
I'll put like half a banana in there or
something like that do they add anything
else in there no just straight up milk
formulated
all right perfect ratios you could throw
a banana in there scientifically uh
proven perfect ratios okay all right
that's good uh go to Wawa get the drinks
go to Vitamin Shop get this stuff go to
if you're in Texas go to HEB go to HEB
rolling hot and get yourself some milk
that's what I'm saying uh also get some
origin hunt originusa.com you can get a
bunch of you can get jeans boots you
know you can get but you can get stuff
that's made in America not stuff that's
literally made
in a tyrannical country like the one we
just talked about
it's a little bit different but the
principles are kind of there let's not
support that let's support America where
people are free
how about that that's a good idea
originusa.com get yourself some boots
jeans some Jiu Jitsu gear ghee
it's true also you want to represent why
you're on this path like I think a lot
of us do pretty much every day chocolate
store.com shirts hats hoodies on there
as well I know it's summertime I get it
but at some point it's going to be fall
then winter got some hoodies on there
um discipline equals Freedom that's what
you're representing the Jocko store
stuff uh short Locker by the way
what I don't know that I've that you've
ever told me your assessment of the
shirt Locker in any thorough way because
she I like it
there's my assessment
if you didn't know what that is
subscription situation get a new shirt
every month creative they're different
different designs
pretty much every single one has been a
success varying levels of you know there
are sporadic
um outliers that might you know they
might be too hard there's a couple
objections over objections the the
conceptual element behind them might
have went over some people's heads
or maybe hit him too hard or hit him too
hard right in the face yeah a little bit
that's what it seems like sherlocker.com
is that a thing no no it's just
jacostore.com I'm just making up my
old.com
Jocko store.com you is a big thing
click shirt Locker check it out you can
see some previews too that's the thing
look I'm not gonna give it all away
you know as far as what designs are what
or whatever but you can see some
previews some hints of like what the
next one is what some past ones were
also if you're a member you can buy any
of the past ones by the way that's
pretty legit yeah so you know you
thought you missed out on one then where
you can drop it back but you can bring
it right back you want your neighbor
because this is that this happens a lot
where you're gonna be wearing one and
someone be like bro where'd you get that
shirt like the one that says good right
you know we have some good shirts on the
store cool now we got a better one
there's or a different one a slightly
and it's like it's cool it looks really
good and I got a literal phone call
saying where who got that shirt where
can we get that shirt my wife wants it
you sign up you can get your wife one
your neighbor one Whatever You Like same
thing check uh that's jocklestore.com
subscribe to the podcast check out the
Jocko underground we just recorded a
couple episodes of that talking
interesting information talk about
keeping our own little platform we have
our own little platform we don't own
this platform that you're listening to
unless you're in Jocko underground right
now but we don't own uh iTunes we don't
own Spotify we don't own YouTube we get
kicked off any of those I don't know
we talked about the Nazis today will
that get us kicked off oh yeah huh yeah
I mean who knows yeah there's like terms
that get you like get flagged kind of
flagged yeah
yeah they're for real are in fact it's
so um before uh yeah we've been flagged
a few times
and that's kind of what prompted this
Jocko underground.com because we don't
know when we're gonna get kicked off for
saying something
yeah so if you want to support that
eight dollars and 18 cents a month we
appreciate it check out the YouTube
channel check out psychological warfare
check out flipsidecanvas.com Dakota
Meyer making awesome stuff to hang on
your wall I've written a bunch of books
check them out uh you know what they are
Echelon front talked about that a little
bit today leadership lab FTX we got the
muster coming up
so I think that's the next one is in
Atlanta hotlanta October 12th to the
14th we sold out all these things so if
you want to come get there early
register go to extreme ownership.com for
our or that's echelonfront.com if you
want to do online training we'll go
through some courses you want to
understand this stuff at a deeper level
go to extreme ownership.com
and take some courses some online
courses I'll be sitting there telling
you what's up
you can come and ask me questions
extreme ownership.com
and if you want to do your duty from a
charity perspective check out Mark Lee's
mom mama Lee she's got a great charity
organization and if you want to donate
to her
organization or you want to get involved
go to America's Mighty Warriors dot org
and you've also got Heroes and horses
dot org Micah he's up there in the
wilderness
they're wrapping up their course right
now 41 days out in the bush
reconnecting with your soul
that's for veterans check it out
heroesandhorses.org and if you wanna
well if you want to see us on Twitter or
the gram or the Facebook
Echo and iron there but look just be
careful fair warning the algorithm's
there the brainwashing out we said
people getting brainwashed
by the Nazis you're getting brainwashed
too when you're staring at that little
screen don't let it happen watch out for
the algorithm
and finally salute to the greatest
generation
the World War II veterans that fought
against the Nazi
power
The Tyranny the oppression
the greatest Generation that saved
freedom in our world so a salute to them
and also thanks to the soldiers Sailors
Airmen and Marines
that are out there right now as we speak
holding the line
thank you to all of you and the same
goes to our police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics EMTs dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
Secret Service and all the First
Responders that keep us safe every day
thank you for holding the line here at
home
and everyone else out there remember
this idea
remember to begin your day with a
mission
begin the day with a mission
and if you approach every day
and you approach every task as if it was
a battle
eventually
you can approach battles like they're a
task
that's what we've got for today
every day is a battle
go get in the fight
and until next time this is Echo and
Jocko out